I
in our morning rounds a new
understanding of the connection between
your head and your heart for the first
time a study shows how signs of stress
and sit in a specific part of the brain
could predict future heart trouble CBS
News medical contributor that's dr. Tara
narula is a cardiologist at Lenox Hill
Hospital in New York City and joins us
at the table so once again it shows your
body's all connected we all know that
stress is contained affects your heart
so what is different about this study
that doctors didn't know before that's
tied to the brain we know that stress
affects the cardiovascular system but
how what's the mechanism and that's
really what this study did it's the
first imaging study that shows us a
particular area of the brain the
amygdala and a pathway that connects it
to arterial inflammation which is the
beginnings of atherosclerosis or black
so researchers in this study looked at
300 individuals they did pet-ct scans on
them and then they followed them for the
development of cardiovascular events
when that what they found with the
imaging is that in the brain the level
of activity of the amygdala was strongly
predictive of those future
cardiovascular events in addition those
level of the amygdala if it was highly
active it predicted that you would have
in a cardiovascular event sooner so the
timing was related and then the most
interesting thing to me is really the
pathway that was elucidated and what
they found is that not only was the
amygdala lit up but also the bone marrow
lit up and that means that the bone
marrow is producing these white blood
cells these inflammatory cells in
addition the arterial walls lit up and
that's really what they had papa size as
the pathway amygdala leads to increase
of white blood cells leads to
inflammation which affects the arterial
wall whereas a MIG de lo I'm trying to
think should we be protecting that we
should see where is it this is a very
deep primitive part of the brain there
two of them one on the right one on the
left almond shaped and basically they
are like the warning center of the brain
so that it's there to kind of detect
threat to detect danger and then it
elicits a response to that a stress
response it's also the seat of emotional
memory the things that are emotionally
important to you you'll form memories in
that area in addition emotional
reactions so things like fear aggression
arousal all housed in the amygdala it's
not so you can be happy that you have a
good brain
yeah so so what can we do about this
right that's really what people want to
know yeah so we obviously need a lot
more research on this particularly in
humans we have a lot more animal
research but certainly meditation
visualization mindfulness has been shown
to actually shrink and change the
amygdala sighs they did a study at
Harvard a couple years ago in addition
psychotherapy the hope is that by
elucidating these pathways as I
mentioned we might be able to develop
novel therapeutics drugs vaccines in the
future and then in animal studies
neurobiologists have shown that finding
outlets for your frustration finding a
social connectedness that helps so there
are techniques that people can use Gaels
or connectors connectiveness having good
friends yes I do is dress scale how do
you do with stress cuz I don't think
you're ever stressed out nothing I'm
aware of that certainly must be yeah you
don't feel stress either do i I really
don't i wish i had a great story but
again you're right you don't know me
don't ya maybe i do and i don't know it
yeah well it's good that you don't feel
I mean most of the people i talked to my
office when i asked them i always ask
about stress it is a cardiovascular risk
factor they'll say yes I'm medium or
high level so for most Americans it's a
big deal thank you something you can do
about it there's a bottom line yeah to
thank you dr. Karen relic in a few